[Musica]
il 12 marzo del 2020 un quotidiano in
italia pubblica nazionale in prima
pagina pubblica un titolo
straordinariamente difficile da
accettare
l'italia chiude
effettivamente la nostra vita allora
lavora è cambiata e non poco per mesi
non siamo più riusciti ad entrare in un
museo visitare una musica nel cinema
ascoltare un concerto
c'è da dire che in tutto ciò c'è stato
un profondo cambiamento un maggiore
utilizzo del telefono posso dire la
curatrice d'arte che effettivamente
molte operazioni legate alla cultura si
siano trasferite su mezzi digitali
e allora la domanda che noi ci poniamo è
questa quanto importante la tecnologia
per la diffusione della cultura
bisogna fare dei in un qualche modo dei
pensieri a riguardo
tutti voi avrete sicuramente un account
facebook un account instagram un account
twitter
sicuramente giorno dopo giorno twittate
o comunque postate foto vostre personali
e lavorative
vi do un dato ed indicare più o meno
l'amore di ciò di cui sto pagando ogni
anno solo sui social nel mondo vengono
pubblicate mille miliardi di fotografia
e mentre sono qui a parlare con voi ogni
due secondi solo in america vengono
pubblicate in rete più fotografia di
quelle prodotte nell'inter 800
e ora la domanda che noi ci poniamo è
qual è il valore di una singola immagine
quale può essere il valore dell'opera
d'arte nella sua unicità in un mondo in
cui viviamo attraverso le ripetizioni
chiunque di voi abbia ti toc vede che
non c'è più originali vince la
ripetizione andiamo per ordine
marzo 2020 l'italia chiude ed
effettivamente io mi son sentita fratta
devo dirlo non mi sentivo così forse da
quando ero adolescente devo dire che
allora quando avevo 16 anni successo un
qualcosa di straordinario e cioè che
conobbi una persona inaspettata che mi
disse qualcosa che si viveva molto
profetico nella mia vita che oggi è
diventato un mantra e cioè che un libro
ti cambia la vita
da allora ad oggi è passato un po di
tempo e mi sono creata un'idea mia tutta
personale di cosa possa essere un
paradiso il paradiso per me maria
vittoria è un enorme libreria contenente
libri che possono raccontare vite che
non avevo che non ancora vissuto o
magari che non vivo sa mai
e tutto molto difficile
e tutto molto strano in questo mondo in
cui
la vita è stata in
è stata contaminata dai media devo dire
che durante questo gap down però ho
trovato un'ulteriore libro che avevo già
detto che mi ha salvato e quindi o ci
tengo a condividerlo con voi
il titolo è le città invisibili di italo
calvino
che un pò di voi conosca calvino sa che
è talmente grande e sterminato il suo
pensiero che talvolta contiene
moltitudini in un momento storico in cui
noi eravamo costretti a stare a casa in
cui raggio d'azione che hanno le nostre
quattro mura domestiche
avevo bisogno di un protagonista in cui
immedesimarmi ed è stato marco poco
perché vi può comincia con marco polo
esploratore che viene chiamato da google
a cannes
per recensire il suo impero un lungo
viaggio un po che mille e una notte in
cui marco polo debba capire cosa
effettivamente sia un impegno
difficilissimo da organizzare
diversissimo quando vi porterà sultano
tutto quello che lui ha capito unendo le
menti veri elementi di fantasia cupola
cannone in realtà interessato agli
aspetti fantastici dell'immaginazione di
ognuno
no alle città che vorremmo vivere voi
interessato a quel mondo che è la realtà
e dice una cosa particolare dice che
vuole sapere tutto di quello che è
l'inferno dei viventi
e di marco polo ci stupisce a calvino ci
stupisce ci legge dentro e ci da due
risposte due modalità desistenza che noi
possiamo scegliere a cui noi possiamo
atterrarci la prima modalità desistenza
in realtà è un pochino più banale
consentitemi il termine perché dice che
alla fine si vive questo inferno di
vivente e senza fare alcunché
il piano piano noi ci assumiamo al mare
in un qualche modo noi non ce ne
renderemo neanche più conto di quanto il
male sia male però è ovviamente la
scelta di marco poco ricade su questa
seconda opportunità ce n'è un'altra una
più coraggiosa una che prevede un'azione
gentile e dice che in realtà l'inferno
dei viventi o si può vivere in un modo
coraggioso e cioè scoprire cosa
nell'inferno non sia inferno
isoradio farlo durare e dargli spazio
è strepitoso
trovare cosa nell'inferno non è inferno
iso rago fago durare il senso della
durata e dagli spazio
calvino ci mette di fronte è come tutti
i pensatori gli artisti chiunque abbia
la pretesa di spiegare di essere umano
ad un duplice codice ad un binario a due
campionati diversi perché l'essere umano
talvolta è in un qualche modo raccontato
da ambivalenze insanabile
essere umano a differenza di qualunque
altra specie animale ha necessità
filosofica
s'interroga da dove venga dove andrà
cosa succederà dopo la sua morte
abbiamo ascoltato
e talmente radicato nel qui e ora che ha
studiato i corpi e cieco e remore come
l'atomo fino ad arrivare alla scissione
dello stesso e se comando vuole essere
protetto in un qualche modo e quindi si
concentra nell'infinitamente piccolo
perché questo rassicura
però noi non siamo solo questo e come
con la stessa forza di evasione con la
stessa mania del con toro ci piace
perdere e ci piace naufragar in quella
sterminata vastità che è universo vi
ricordate no
leopardi la siepe il confine di mina le
più a quello che è certo è ciò che ci
piace
ove per poco il cor non si spaura e i
naufraghi m'è dolce in questo mare
perché vi dico tutte queste cose perché
queste ambivalenze questa visione del
weekend questa visione di una realtà più
complessa
viene abbracciata in vari ambiti in cui
l'essere umano agisce
noi abbiamo una visione
duplice anche del tempo
chiunque di noi ha una visione
nostalgica
soprattutto noi occidentali
no la nostra letteratura comincia con
ulisse che torna a casa
ulisse che rinuncia alla mortalità per
tornare dalla sua famiglia
eppure la nostra nostalgia non è solo
del passato la nostalgia e del futuro
vi faccio un esempio vi dico queste cose
perché perché anche il mondo della
cultura mondo dei reali del mondo della
fotografia
e in un qualche modo interisa di queste
istanze
vi faccio un esempio quando noi parliamo
soprattutto in italia all'estero è
diverso dei nostri beni culturali
la paura che vince sempre non è bene
culturale i beni indicano qualcosa che
vanno in qualche modo ottimizzati
sfruttati noi parliamo di patrimonio e
capite bene che la prova patrimonio
anche nella costituzione viene citato
non è una parola
a caso non è una parola neutra è una
parola intrisa di malinconia
ma perché patrimonio dal latino e ciò
che i padri ci hanno lasciato e di per
sé e ciò che vende quello che noi siamo
oggi più degni di essere in un qualche
modo rappresentati
allora quando noi parliamo del nostro
patrimonio della nostra alte di tutto
ciò che ci riguarda noi abbiamo un
atteggiamento di salvaguardia di cura
tutto deve essere ricordato noi siamo un
concentrato di memoria e come dice
battiato nella cura l'amore e non far
morire l'amore è far ricordare
che se comanda è strano
è straordinario e questo tema della
memoria ricovero e voi direte certo vi
quali dalla nostra vita reale invece no
i guai dalla nostra vita più caldo
digitale vi faccio un esempio la memoria
agisce sempre su due binari la memoria
deve ricordare e gli avversari il
ricordo prende con segmento e venduto in
un qualche modo sempre alla portata del
pensiero ma soprattutto la memoria deve
compiere un'altra operazione che
altrettanto fondamentale che in un
qualche modo cura di filtrare ciò che va
ricordato e cosa no
altrimenti faremo la fine di funes e il
memorioso non so se avevo conosciate
funes è un uomo di una novella di borges
che si ricorda tutto
si ricorda tutti indistintamente se noi
di un tavolo imbandito apparecchiato
potremmo ricordarci vedendo un secondo
due bicchieri un tavolo un tovagliolo
funes si ricorda esattamente
tutti i boccioli dei fiori del percolato
guardando le nuvole riesce in un qualche
modo a
comparare a quelle che ha letto su un
ripido di una che non ha restituito
funes faccio breve in realtà è un
disadattato perché chi ricorda tutto in
realtà non sa più niente
questo è un grande rischio che noi non
viviamo nella realtà questo rischio noi
viviamo nella rete e non sono qui per
pagare di quanto che avete possa essere
una discarica di informazioni in cui
effettivamente è difficile orientarsi
no anche perché il novecento quel secolo
breve
gli anni 2000 i social tecnologia hanno
innescato un processo di
democratizzazione incredibilmente
interessante virtuoso
chiunque di voi sono certo almeno una
volta nella vita sarà andato a vedere la
galleria degli uffizi i musei vaticani
la cappella degli scrovegni
ecco solo 100 anni fa questa cosa non
sarebbe stata possibile perché erano
luoghi in un qualche modo chiusi
destinati a piccole piccoli manipoli di
persone
superheavy tavi super esclusivi
oggi noi abbiamo le possibilità
prenotando una visita pagando un
biglietto prendendo un treno mostrando
in passa effettivamente di fare questa
esperienza
l'esperienza può essere avvicinato
attraverso il social siamo d'accordo
chiunque di voi può attraverso instagram
attraverso google scoprire qualcosa che
non conosceva tuttavia l'esperienza
artistica non può assolutamente
essere considerata digitale l'esperienza
artistica richiede presenza esattamente
come un libro comincia ad esistere
quando qualcuno corregge io sono
fermamente convinta che l'opera d'arte
esiste sia completa quando qualcuno a
guarda la vista di savi questo è mancato
in questi anni
vi dico vi racconto una storia per farvi
capire quanto la presenza sia
fondamentale
quanto bisogna andare anche ad una
singola immagine ad una singola
fotografia c'è una storia questa
riguarda l'inizio del 900 persone di un
uomo che ha avuto patriottico che altro
studioso un decoratore che lavorava gola
e lui era talmente innamorato della
gioconda di lonato che è sfuggito un
piano molto vo campo esco perdonatemi
devo palla e ce la fece
con spirito di riportarlo in italia
perché noi potessimo godere del nostro
patrimonio
direte cosa è successo quando era la
gioconda quando monnalisa venne rubata
qualcosa che nessuno mai si sarebbe
immaginato
ovvero che persone da tali g dai paesi
vicini dall'italia andarono si misero in
fuga aspettavano e contemplavano per
qualche minuto il muro bianco spoglio il
segno che la cornice aveva impresso nel
tempo i chiodi che reggevano la tara di
monna lisa
monna mia signora mea domina lisa
e come perché vi dico queste cose perché
l'esperienza e questo l'esperienza sc
come dicevo umberto eco
che diceva che in qualche modo alter
avete attua solo un'immortalità
all'indietro
questo quello che succede quando voi
guardate un'opera d'arte
e ora io vi invito voi non dovete
seguire quello che diceva barawe vi fate
un pitcher a calvino fate un piacere a
marco polo che di viaggi straordinari se
ne intendeva andate a ruba
andate a vedere monna lisa e vi dirò
succederà una cosa straordinaria sapete
perché l'esperienza di un paradiso non
ancora vissuto perché quando vedrete
monnalisa voi non coldiretti è solo una
donna del
1506 valeo guidare voi è quello sguardo
enigmatico
e non solo sarete voi a poter guardare
gli occhi che hanno visto che a nardò e
avrete la possibilità per una manciata
di istanti di solito succede di
ritornare indietro nel tempo di capire
cosa effettivamente il rinascimento fu
cosa fu la vita di un genio
incredibile giocato su più paese sui
tagli sulla francia potrete fare
esperienza di tutto ciò che noi oggi
rischiamo di dimenticare
e allora anche se ci chiudono il
rimpasto anche se difficili anche se ce
l'hanno reso forse meno piacevole voi
questo favore a marco poco ma dovete
fare e allora capirete che in futuro ha
un volto antico che i maestri e bisogna
meritarseli ma dovete mostrare coraggio
e capire cosa nell'inferno non è inferno
cercare di fare durare e dargli spazio
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]